hello everyone and welcome to the most
requested game of the European Club cup
so far it's from round five and it's
board one Daniel D versus Shah mamaro I
don't know maybe the H is not silent
maybe it's Daniel dka Belgian
Grandmaster and he already won the
Belgian Championship three times and he
did it the first time when he was only
13 years old so very very strong player
but uh on the other side of the board it
is a former 2800 you know absolute Beast
Shak mamedyarov so let's see what
happened here and why the game was
requested so many times so Daniel has
the white pieces and he opens with D4 we
have Knight to F6 by Shak uh C4 G6 and
now countering this Kings Indian defense
setup with Pawn to H4 now it has been
played before and even by some very
strong players for example Magnus
Carlson played it once against Maxim vag
gravin won a very nice game also ding
Len played it against mvl I think they
drew their game so Bishop to G7 Knight
to C3 Knight to C6 and now Knight Knight
to F3 so the Four Knights are out and we
have this inclusion of Pawn to H4 and
the couple of games that reach this
position D6 was played in all of them
but here we have um C sorry D6 was
played by all of them but here we have
castles and it is now as of move five
already that we have a completely new
game now someone mentioned in the
previous video that uh whenever I say
it's a completely new game that it's not
that they have access to the new
database big database 2023 and they are
like hundreds of online games well yes I
don't use that database I use a database
that only uh takes games from Top tier
tournaments so uh for example if you and
your grandma or or grandfather you know
just play a game online uh somewhere it
will be in some database it will just
not be in the big one for important
tournament so usually when I say it's a
completely new move I mean for you know
in top tier tournaments where players
are rated U at least 2,000 or above
something like that I don't know what
the exact criteria is but of course it
is possible that somewhere in the world
this position has been reached somewhere
uh but that being said uh let's check it
out we have castles and now Pawn to D5
challenging the Knight here we have
Knight to B4 and now Pawn to G3 here uh
you could challenge the Knight yes and
you could even get B4 in but uh you know
it could be a little bit dangerous with
the bishop um Bishop's Diagon will open
like this and the Knight will be very
safe here C6 will be played then the
Knight comes to C 7 if you play B5 the
Knight can come to C5 so it's not really
a dangerous expansion for black so G3 we
have Pawn to E6 and only Now Pawn to A3
Knight to A6 and Bishop to G2 continuing
development we have e captures on D5 of
course it makes sense to open up the
position as the white king is still in
the center of the board C captures on D5
and now Rook to E8 with have castles and
now Knight to C5 this is an excellent
Square for the Knight um and uh of
course while while you do want to kick
it away with B4 here it would again uh
not be advised as it would allow for
some very nasty discoveries so after
Knight C5 Pawn to D6 going after the
doubling of the black pawns and now Pawn
to C6 here mov says I'm just going to
develop put my Rook here put my Bishop
on f8 and I'm going to win that pawn so
that is not the the best way to treat
this position we have Knight to D2 and
now we have Pawn to A5 stopping Pawn to
B4 before going after the D6 Pawn B3 and
now Rook to E6 so why did Daniel push
this Pawn all the way well he's counting
on getting some very very important
tempy on that rook and getting a lot of
development in so Queen to C2 of course
you want to get the Queen off of the D
file Rook captur on D6 now Knight to C4
we have Rook back to E6 and now Bishop
to E3 now with the idea of uh chasing
away the Knight and then getting
the the full control over the B6 quick
where so here we have Bishop to f8 also
you have to defend the Knight as the
Knight is hanging and now Bishop to H3
attacking The Rook here Rook back back
to E8 and now Pawn to B4 so now the
bishop and Knight have very nice control
over the B6 square if um shakri moves
the Knight but he doesn't of course he
plays Pawn to D5 now this is hanging
okay the Knight on C5 is hanging but
also the Knight on C4 is singing and
also the bishop on H3 is singing so how
do you play this uh Bishop captures on
C8 of of course Queen captures on C8 and
now you just take the piece Bishop
captures on C5 and how does Shaker play
this of course he does not take back he
plays Queen captures on H3 first
although you could capture back right
away this is you know a bit more poetic
uh now threatening Knight to G4 and you
just want to Checkmate the white king so
of course Knight back to D2 you have to
stop this if you if you go for Bishop
captures on f8 then Knight G4 just ends
the game so you have to be ready for
this Knight to D2 now getting ready to
meet Knight to G4 with Knight to F3 so
the Knight on F3 guards the H2 square
but even this is not possible uh for
reasons that will be revealed here we
have Bishop captures on
C5 uh grabbing uh grabbing that piece B
captures and now Knight to G4
threatening mate in one so Knight to F3
stopping mate in one but now feel free
to pause the video and try to find this
incredibly incredible series of moves
for shakar while I give you a couple of
seconds and also this will reveal why
this game was suggested so many times so
have at it and for those of you who
haven't seen it I'm sure this will be
quite a treat to to
[Music]
enjoy so for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations and always
looking for weaknesses in wh's Camp
around the around the king and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Rook the e E3 yes we are going to
do it in slow motion most definitely
there we go Rook to E3 uh so big
congratulations to everyone who founded
this and now you will see why you cannot
take the Rook of course you would very
much love to but then you lose control
over the G3 pawn and after this uh
Knight captures on E3 attacks the queen
attacks the rook and threatens Checkmate
and once you stop Checkmate just one
check and then you pick up the queen and
of course uh you're just up a full Queen
so what can you do after Rook to E3 well
you have to clear the F1 Square for your
king So Rook F to E1 now the king can go
to F1 after you eliminated the defender
of the H2 Square that's kind of the
point of Rook E3 of course you want to
eliminate this Knight but now comes Rook
8 to E8 and this is the only way to to
win this because now if you just go for
this capture it doesn't really do all
that much Queen H2 checking to F1 and
there's no continuation Queen H3 check
the king actually escapes via the E2
square and it doesn't matter if you go
Rook to H check King to D2 and the white
king escapes so the idea behind this
incredible Rook 88 move is that once you
do all of this the king will not have
the E2 Square as it will be guarded by
the other Rook so how do you continue
now again you cannot capture this now
it's even worse as you you just get
checkmated right on the spot if King H1
Knight to F2 is a nice Checkmate and if
you go King F1 Knight captures on E3 is
a nice Checkmate so after Rook a E8 uh
Daniel tried uh Queen to D3 He already
wants some material so he wants to give
up the Queen maybe survive this H but as
Shak will show it does not work so Rook
captures on D3 e captures on D3 and now
look at this Rook to E3 once again
that's what Shak madaro played and he
was in this position on move 27 that
Daniel darta resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here so uh
even quicker than what Magnus did to
Vincent it took Magnus 29 moves to to
defeat Vincent and here mamar does it in
27 moves with the black pieces u i mean
with with such incredible sacrifices
absolutely incredible and now again the
idea is absolutely the same of course
the Knight here is hanging and if you
just you're already down a queen if you
give a knight then there's nothing to
talk about here uh so you might capture
The Rook or you could even go for Rook
captures on E3 it doesn't matter Knight
captures on E3 and okay you could say I
have captures and I have two knights and
The Rook for a queen no you don't you
most certainly do not Queen captures
with check doesn't matter where you go
because the uh Knight will hang with
check you could go to F1 and then King C
Queen captures here and it doesn't
matter if you go here then you start
capturing here now you have a knight and
The Rook for a queen if you go here then
even Queen to H1 check picks up the Rook
on A1 so there is absolutely nothing you
can do here after Rook to E3 the only
thing Daniel could do is uh maybe stand
up and you know give U Shak there a nice
Applause and I'm I'm kind of hoping
that's what happened because this game
would definitely deserve it so there we
have it you've seen why so many people
were requesting it Shah M former 2800
you know doesn't matter the time form it
uh if it's his day he will uh deliver a
masterpiece like this uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it and in
the previous video Someone said that
okay that was a really really nice game
that I I should have made like at least
a 20 minute video on it but uh i' I've
covered all the lines that um should
have been covered I I mean I I could try
to make lines longer and make more lines
that I just don't think that are
relevant but I whenever I cover a game I
I show you all the lines that I myself
think are are worthy of showing and I
don't care how long the video takes
sometimes it's a 5 minute video
sometimes it's a 15 sometimes 25 I've
even made like a 35 minute video because
there were so many lines to cover but
you know I I covered them and the the
length is as as the length is so what
are you going to do so yeah once again
really hope you guys enjoyed it if you
have any other gems that you would like
to see from the 30th European Club cup
do use # suggestion in in the comment
section below I would like to thank dreo
is the best data Lake engine K Ingram
Dennis shono hoodie guy and the brers on
Spotify for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on new wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
uh so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your
day